want to finish me the rest of it for me
this has been a very difficult time for
me and I'd like to find all those people
by some expressed by mr. support for me
I would also like to thank the jury for
their verdicts today however this is
Mike Lee's verdict today is not a cause
for celebration
how can I celebrate with my son lies
buried
when I cannot see him or speak to him
when will I see you now see him grow up
and go to university we'll get married
or have children these words will bring
will not bring my son back how can I
celebrate when I molex this day could
have come 18 years ago
if the police who were meant to find my
son my son killers felt so miserable to
do so these are not a reason to
celebrate all I now feel is relief
really but two of my son killers have
finally been caught and brought to
justice relief at least racist men can
no longer think that they can murder
can murder a black man and get away with
it
relief that despite the defense being
able to raise issues of contamination
the jury saw through it I feel you leave
that to some extent I can move forward
with my life but mix this relief is
anger
I give that me and my family were put
through 18 years of grief and
uncertainty not known if or when we ever
get justice have the police done they
done their job properly I would have
spent the last 18 years breathing for my
son rather than fighting to get his
killer support I have that despite the
police saying that this case was so
important to them the exhibits were
treated in such way the defense did
suggest contamination this result shows
that the police can do their jobs
properly but only if they only if they
want to I only hope that they have
learned their lesson and and don't put
any other family through what we have
been put through the fact is that racism
and racist attacks are still happening
in this country and the police should
not use
my son's name to say that we can leave
on novice we have some sort of justice I
want people to think of Stephen other
than a black teen later murdered in a
racist attack in southeast London in
April 1993 I know this the fact but I
now want people to remember him as a
bright beautiful young man who any
parent of whatever background would have
been proud of he was a wonderful son and
a shining example of what many repair
always wanted in a child I'm missing
with a passion hopefully now you can
rest in case
my client Neville Lawrence has asked me
to read his statement my life was torn
apart by the senseless murder of my son
over 18 years ago
unfortunately no one was brought before
a court at that time as they should feel
the loss itself together with the lack
of justice have meant that I have not
been able to rest all this time I am
therefore full of joy and relief that
today finally two of my son's killers
have been convicted for his murder they
will be sent to prison and forced to
face the consequences of their actions
consequences which my family and I have
been living with all these years I would
like to thank the police and prosecutors
for their faultless preparation and
delivery of the case I would like to
thank the judge for the work he's put in
to ensure that the suspects had a fair
trial I thank the jury for their careful
attention to my son's case day after day
and the verdicts that they have
delivered something has happened over
the last seven weeks I have watched
justice feel done as for me I'm not sure
where I will go from here I will let
this good news sink in for some time
however I'm also conscious of the fact
that there were five or six attackers
that night I do not think I will be able
to rest until they are all brought to
justice